- Nice hat.
- Oh, thanks man.
- Makes you look really cool.
- Thanks.
- I bet you get compliments all the time.
- Sure do.
(lighthearted music)
- Ooh, that's a great hat.
- Oh, you think so?
- Mm-hmm.
It looks so good on you,
you should totally buy it.
- I don't know.
Every time I try something new
my friends just make fun of me.
Plus I don't think I'm a hat guy.
- I totally disagree.
I think you're a hat guy.
And I think you look handsome.
(cash register rings)
And you are all set, Elijah.
- Thanks.
I'm a hat guy.
(upbeat music)
Hey.
Hola.
You talkin' to me?
Hi, I'm Elliott.
Hi, how are you?
(grunting)
Oh, hey.
Yup.
- Nice hat, douche.
(clears throat)
(upbeat music)
- Hi.
- Oh, hey guys.
- Sarah, up here.
- We made a series.
- It's coming on November 18th.
- Please watch it.
- Get it here.
- [All] There, here. Over there.
- I think they got it, okay.
- You can see it.
It'll be released 2015, November.
Okay.